I wanted to tell you a couple stories so
again I'm Larry gray I'm going to tell
you two stories so I had friends tell me
when I Was preparing this you know how
should I go about doing this and
everyone was like tell a story that's
like but I love telling stories so this
is good so the first story I'm going to
tell you is here is a picture of the
island of Tasmania south of Australia
and I went there for vacation and my
idea of what I wanted to do on this
island is I wanted to explore the east
coast of this island and so I landed in
Launceston here uh Launceston on
Tasmania and I was going to take a bus
and travel around the island stopping at
all the coastal towns so my way from
Launceston to Saint Helens which was my
first stop I stayed at a hostel and I
ran into this guy as a Nepalese guy
named Johnny so Johnny and I both went
around St Helens and exploring the beach
which is better Long Bay this picture
here is from Bill Long Bay Tasmania yeah
and we walked that beach and hung out
and went to the old growth rainforest
and hung out and Johnny and I became
very good friends over this short period
of time and we were getting ready to
leave and Johnny I was getting ready to
take a bus and Johnny was like Hey
brother I was like yes it's like we
don't take buses around here we're gonna
hitchhike and I was like no
that's not happening and but after a
while he convinced me and so we go out
to the highway I put out my thumb and an
old lady in a Bentley pulls up it's like
do you need a ride and we're like oh my
gosh this is this is happening like this
was so I jump in the car and she's very
nice she takes us to the next stop again
we do this and someone else a family
picks us up with their kids in the car
and we're like this is just absolutely
amazing and I realize I'm part of this
community in which I'm participating in
and there's a high level of trust and
safety in this community right in which
people are actively part participating
there's this sense of belonging and
there's networks that's happening so
this happens all the way to Hobart at
the bottom here we get there and I fly
back to Mainland Australia I'm just so
impressed that I want other people to
participate in this community so I call
a friend and say say Hey you have to
come to Tasmania you won't believe it
we're going to do this and she comes
same as that thing you know people pull
over pick us up and we're having a blast
we're enjoying this community right and
I had this idea it's like what if I
could transform that type of community
into other parts of my life like and so
we ended up going the last leg of my
Trope with my friend we caught a ride
with a college student
and it's like yeah you can stay at our
place tonight hang out and so I get
there and I get into the house and I
hear Hey Brother
it's Johnny it's like I run into Johnny
again on this trip so this happened so I
never take Johnny's information this is
passing Seasons we'll never see each
other again so I go back to the States
eight months later I decide I'm going to
come back to Australia like hey I really
enjoy it there I'm thousands of miles
away from Tasmania I'm out at a cafe and
I hear Hey Brother
randomly and it's Johnny like in the
middle of the street like random cafe
and it was but and it kind of came up
this whole network this whole thing of
just Destiny and all this stuff type
things but the real part about Tasmania
was this ideal of community in which
people could are trusting or loving or
caring and so the Second Story I wanted
to tell you about how that applies to my
adventure and coming to uh
getting involved in data science
so again it's 20 ideas to build social
capital in the data science ecosystem
so how many of you want to stand out in
the ever competitive data science
ecosystem just sure you just want to
stand out right how many people want to
get involved and don't really know how
right that's why I was right uh I got
started my journey was here at this very
conference in 2017 I made the decision
my life was at a crossroad like I wanted
I was biomedical scientist for 20 years
and I wanted to get into data science
but I didn't know anyone I didn't know
the community and the only thing I found
online was this Pi data New York City
conference going on and I thought this
is probably the best place for me to go
and it was transformative
right I ended up meeting people at this
conference that five years later would
have great impact in my life
right
so today's talk is about building a
sustainable uh nurturing culture in
which uh we provide a way for others to
be participate in
so the main the big thing that I want to
say about all of this is that
when building Social Capital you have to
do it from a place of being very honest
very honest but it's a very humble place
and a place in which you exists in your
most authentic self like this is very
very very important for this to to work
uh and I know that's a hard ask to to
have but it's essential this is the way
that all of this works and why do I even
care
is that I really want to build a diverse
uh inclusive community within data
science right I really I stare at this
room I don't really see anyone that
looks like me like I really want that
environment where it reflects me right
uh in reverse and not diverse in many
aspects not just race
so I'm going to introduce you to three
different people that I met in 2017 that
eventually had large impact on my life
right I met them not even knowing who
they were really someone introduced me
to them so yeah you should you should
talk to this guy Travis I don't know if
you guys know who Travis is but he's the
reason why we're here today all right
um but I didn't know him at the time I
just knew this guy Travis and he went we
had a conversation but he's the creator
of numpy side pie he's the CEO of open
teams plenty you know start it help
start numb Focus
but I ran it to him there's another guy
named Eric Ma and if you've been in a
pie data circuit you would see him give
a talk but Eric uh he's a scientist at
moderna uh and he's
he's also everything Bayesian if you
want to know anything Bayesian he's the
guy to talk to and he's also a
maintainer for a package called pie
janitor
so Eric helped me out quite a bit and
then Katrina who is sitting in the front
row
who I met in 2017 and we really didn't
talk much until like five years later
and we're in a meeting together and it's
like I know you it's like where do I
know you from right and it's this 2017
conference uh and it was an important
meeting and it was it was good
so let's talk uh briefly about social
capital so Social Capital can be defined
as the networks of relationships uh
among people who live and work in a
particular ecosystem enabling that
ecosystem to function effectively right
at a very very high level of Social
Capital a good relationship with a lot
of people who have access to valuable
resources right for Social Capital to
obtain a high level you need certain
elements there has to be a sense of
belonging there has to be high levels of
safety and Trust reciprocity
participation citizen power in which the
citizens have the power to affect the
community in which they live in if
values LED driven diversity and building
networks Bridges and bonds with each
other all these elements need to be in
place in order for this to happen and
what I'm going to talk about it here is
not only at the more Global at the
global layer in which a social capital
is built to support the entire ecosystem
there's also at an individual level in
which Social Capital exists and it
exists in which resources are embedded
in a social network that will bring
benefit to the owners that's at the
individual level
so the idea is first idea attend a
conference that's the first thing that I
did you all accomplish this you should
be proud of yourself you attended a
conference but it's not simply just
attending a competency there are other
conferences such as python sci-fi Pi
data Global all these conferences that
you can participate in right so the big
thing about doing this is a
participating in events throughout the
conference so they had open source
Sprints for here on Tuesday you can get
involved allows you to meet up with
maintainers and contributors and really
get involved in the community you can
give a lightning talk that's coming up
this afternoon it just spend five
minutes talking about something that
you're passionate about these are things
that you can do and they help you
individually they help you build up
confidence in order to to do things at
lunch and I this is one of the biggest
ones you sit at a table with people you
do not know this is hard for people but
sit out and trade War stories about data
that's one thing that we all have in
common is about data so you can trade
War Stories right and be fully present
in talks and ask questions and speak
with the speakers I'm more than happy to
speak with each and every one of you
the other part and the volunteers can
attest to this is one of the best ways
to uh to really get out there is to
volunteer at conferences a because
whenever I was in graduate school and
doing this or I was a postdoc I couldn't
afford to go to a lot of conferences so
I would volunteer and get free or
discounted admission uh you get to build
relationships with event hosts like this
is very important I'm going to tell you
a story uh and you get to meet high
profile speakers in a very low stress
environment
so Betsy here is a coordinator I was a
coordinator for her for pycon right and
I've been volunteering she asked me do
you want to meet Guido Von Rossum I was
like but of course do you want to have
lunch with them it's like but but of
course and I met Guido and we hit it off
like we became friends like I I met this
guy and we were later just send emails
back and forth just chatting so this was
a thing in which I met someone I became
involved in something fruitful
came from it and if you want to get
started in this every conference website
generally has a volunteer section a form
just subscribe to conference emails uh
and if that doesn't work contact the
program committee you can become
involved in this and this is a great way
so Guido comes up again in later talks
because he became important for me in
open source software also
so
the next thing that I did so one thing I
should mention is that this is happening
sequentially pretty much in my life like
this has happened over over a period of
time and one of the things that you can
do is give talks at local meetups this
wasn't easy for me at first what I ended
up doing is I would go to the meetings
and just get to know people and then
about a year later I decided to give a
talk right I gave a talk on sentiment
analysis I remember this very clearly
but it gave me a chance to build up my
confidence in speaking at this
conference and getting to know people
and so I'm building out my network
during this time and you can get started
Go to meetup.com search for data data
science any of these key terms and it's
tempting to join them all but but don't
do that right don't join them all kind
of get to know a few of them right
this one is quite interesting uh I
joined a study group and it was a group
of people getting together that would
study a very specific machine learning
topic and we would dive deep into it and
then afterwards we would write blog
posts about what we learned and doing
this it was a great exercise of being in
a room full of people that were doing
this together and it was a great
networking opportunity so I am
I I really suggest that you seek out
these type of opportunities because they
can be really rich opportunities for you
to grow in the way that you make this
happen basically is to access your local
network if you don't have a local
network you can go to Facebook groups
LinkedIn groups and find people that are
interested in these types of things so
there are three people that I wanted to
kind of talk about here so Martin
um who was in the study group with me
Benjamin bank for Dr Benjamin banker and
Dr Rebecca bilbro who I met there that
become very
important in my life as I went on to do
open source software and some other
aspects so
this is what I'm really really
passionate about it's open source
software and I'm a maintainer for Yellow
Brick Yellow Brick is some machine
learning like visual Diagnostics
performance I ran into several people
that know this package which is kind of
cool but it was really great because as
a data scientist one of the skills that
sometimes we lack is our ability our
software development skills right and
this was the opportunity to build those
skills and to learn to build a
maintainable project
all right so and it's also the
opportunity to be part of the data
science and open source software
communities
it is simple go submit a pull request go
to GitHub for the most part for your
favorite project submit a pull request
it could be a typo it could be
documentation it could be a feature but
it's an opportunity for you to get
involved
and if you're looking for packages to
work on well numb Focus has plenty that
you can contribute to uh there's
non-focus supported or physical physical
supported projects and there's
Affiliated projects which yellowbrick is
an Affiliated project and there's like
pandas matplotlib you can contribute to
all of these and they're very open and
welcoming of contributors
so this is fun if you go to my LinkedIn
page you see me with a thumbs up on a
picture because I want a hackathon that
was like really fun uh it was a great
way to test your skills out in the wall
and be creative so this is something you
can do in order to kind of get around
and understand your local community and
so to get started you will search for
local events search for online events
there's devpose that's hacker Irv
there's kaggle these are all places that
where you can get involved right and so
one of the things that you shouldn't you
notice here these are all it seems like
personal things that you can just do to
kind of build up your own self and build
up your resources but we're going to
switch gears to actually talking about
how do you actually build up the social
capital for the entire ecosystem right
so one of the things that I love doing
is joining committees where you can
directly support in this case the data
science and open source software uh
um you can join us and be on these
committees
um be a part of community and how do you
get started like for me
um there you go to websites of like numb
Focus or pycon I'm on a poster committee
I was on a small development grants
committee for numb focus and Affiliated
project selection committee which I'm
the chair of right now but this is a
great way for you to to actually
participate in the community in which
you're when you're doing this you're
counting kind of making the glue a
little stickier for Social Capital right
social capital is the glue that kind of
keeps things going and working and so by
participating you're helping to build
that community
um
one of the things this
uh is interesting so I ended up becoming
adjunct faculty at Georgetown University
because of Dr Benjamin bankert who I
showed before
um
convinced me that this would be great
and you might think okay forget it Larry
you have a PhD that's why you can come
adjunct faculty I actually didn't have
my first status I had I was teaching
data science before I had my first data
science job like it really came down to
skill right more than actual uh me
having a degree and I at this point I
had taught myself for maybe three years
of doing data science right so it's not
impo it's not uh impossible so one of
the great things from doing this is that
you can improve your understanding of
data science fundamentals and you can
introduce this is the community part and
most people this is a way for you to
introduce students into the data science
ecosystem like really important to
getting new people that are joining
involved and you can shape the way that
they involve like the things that we end
up doing we only use open source
software and teaching right get them
involved in the open source Community
also and the side you generate income
right so the way that you get started
with this is through people already
doing this so if you I this is very real
if you want to teach data science or
data analytics come talk to me all right
that's not an empty uh gesture come talk
to me so um you can also reach out to
universities a lot of universities now
have data related certificates and any
Professionals in order to teach those
certificates so
develop coursework this is like a side
um this comes from teaching
again it improves your understanding of
data science fundamentals and you can
generate passive income you get started
by working with a university and so I
ended up developing coursework at
Georgetown because of Dr bang for who I
mentioned earlier nominated me to design
to actually design some courses but I'm
constantly bombarded by Coursera udemy
Corazon educative there's opportunities
to go out there and create courseware
and where people will help and guide you
and make sure that you create content
that's uh that's good content so you
have that opportunity also
don't think that you cannot do it
um
so I'm really happy about this because I
think I discovered something that most
people don't know I moved to Salt Lake
City Utah from Baltimore Maryland
culture shock right and I knew no one
right and I wanted it's during the
pandemic and I really need to reach out
to people right and so what I ended up
doing is like okay I'm gonna get on
LinkedIn I'm going to find all the data
scientists that I can find and I'm going
to reach out to them and so I just send
them very honest messages hey I'm new to
the area uh would you like to chat
sometime and let me know what you're
doing I tell you what I'm doing
99 of the time people like yes sure but
but of course and so I even took it a
step further I was like
what if I talk to people that are in
positions above me that the positions
that I want to get to right what if I
reach out to those people and say
honestly hey I really want to know how
you got to where you're at in your
career right 99 of the time people were
very responsive and would call and talk
to me even given even getting job offers
from a few people just from content and
it was a great way to build out my
network and this was like the stepping
stone for me to actually get involved
more with my local community because I
had a vast
network of just local data scientists
that I built up from just talking to
and
so this comes back to building my local
network in Salt Lake City to trying to
organize a Meetup so it's pandemic the
local Pi data Meetup is defunct no one's
having it and I thought well maybe we
can do virtual all right we'll do a
virtual uh conference
and I go to go look up uh who's
organizing this conference and lo and
behold is Travis oliphon he's the
organizer for this and I was like I Know
Travis so I sent him an email and say
hey I really want to he's not even
living in Salt Lake anymore but he's
still organizing this this Meetup and so
I said hey you know I really want to be
a co-organizer to get this going and it
worked like uh I was able to help build
local community establish relationships
with local influencers and I got started
by leveraging my local Meetup so I
started reaching out to people saying
we're going to have this Meetup and
we're going to start a speaker series
right and we went that and so Travis was
really so Travis also started helping me
whenever I was on a job search also so
he was out there campaigning for me to
get positions and things like that which
was great so he had a dramatic impact on
on my life so sitting on panels this is
kind of a weird one
um
you can get to better understand your
opinions this is pretty cool because you
get to better understand your opinions
on topics on certain topics and learn to
express those opinions clearly to a
receptive audience right it's a big
benefit I don't know if people realize
that being on it on the side of the
table is a big benefit for you also to
better understand how you feel about
things and this is generally the
outgrowth of participating in community
right conferences LinkedIn local and
things like this
so during the pandemic uh there were not
a lot of social events they were
practically none and I had to figure out
a way how do I create a social capital
or Bill a community within my own
organization that's that's that can help
me and help the outside community so I
went to doing something called uh Inc I
went to increase Capital Social Capital
at work and so what I end up doing is
build a data literacy program so people
understand the importance of data within
my organization I start doing things as
teaching python or data science courses
to the staff and the surprising effect
whenever we got out of the pandemic and
I wanted to host events like they were
like yeah you know this data thing is
pretty cool right and so I was building
Capital within my organization that made
them more susceptible to
my suggestions to help the community as
a whole
and so we here today so submit a
conference talk
um
so
to
submit a conference talk
what I end up doing is this wasn't the
first time I submitted a conference talk
and the first one did not go very well
um
it didn't get accepted and but the
benefit of this and I I learned is that
you get to share your passion like I'm
really passionate about building social
capital and meeting new people
the thing is you need to select the
appropriate conference for your talk
right that's the key that's key to this
and review previous proposals so pycon
and Pi data are really good about this
providing that information
so start a data science internship this
gets back into how did we get back to
the community what you're trying to do
here in these cases are Foster growth of
others like this is about them being a
part of the community so you're doing
things and this is very unique because
you're given Hands-On like experiences
to people whenever you're doing this and
you do this through Google summer of
code or through your job
so Eric ma
helped me out a lot with this so I
wanted to start writing blog articles
and what I end up doing is writing
articles and sending them to Eric and he
would proofread everything for me and it
was like we'll go through the cycle and
it would be so welcoming so nice is like
go through this and I just start
publishing constantly to the point that
I was actually had a huge following
behind me just writing blog posts but he
helped me considerably and do that but
there's benefit for this is a you better
understand certain topics that you're
writing about uh you get you're able to
give your unique perspective and I think
this is very important that there should
be a lot of unique perspectives that are
coming out and you make an impact on the
body of data science literature right
and get started open up a medium.com
account and you can just find others
doing this so reviewing books this is
interesting I was able to do this
through other
um uh just knowing people that were
actually writing books and reviewing
them but there's opportunities for you
to go to O'Reilly packet manny.com and
actually explore those opportunities
yourself so this isn't for our fetch in
order to do this
this is different from provide
mentorship is different from internship
this is where you're simply listening
giving advice and providing access to
your network like this is very important
and anyone at any stage can do this
right you can always be a mentor to
someone else all right
and you just need to make yourself
available to others and I know that's a
hard ask at times to make yourself
available but it's important
this might seem out of place be
proactive like I've talked about
everything here but it's actually key to
all of this is just
um being proactive to help maintain and
grow the data science community and you
do it in a way where you it's values
driven and you create your own
circumstance that's what I end up doing
with all of this it's creating my own
circumstances and you should be
proactive
um this is important because you want to
give others the opportunity to grow this
is comes from the mentoring and
everything you want to give people
opportunity to grow and show gratitude
so how you get started with this is just
share knowledge experience in your time
right
and finally Community leadership
positions so the benefits of this is
having a broad impact on community right
and so I was nominated to be on the
board of directors and non-focus and I
mentioned my uh Katrina me and her
seeing each other for the first time in
five years in that Medium is like oh I
know you and I'm thinking like man five
years ago I was nowhere close to any of
this stuff right and slowly I've made my
way up through the community and now
that I'm I'm like overseeing certain
aspects of it like my ability to want or
my desire to actually
give like give back and help this
community be more like Tasmania where we
just walk around and people are like hey
how can I help you hi what do you need
come stay here this is great I would
love to live in that environment in
which uh
um in that environment
so opportunities I would like to explore
I like to write a book on Social Capital
right uh host a Regional Conference have
you guys come out to Salt Lake City and
experience uh what's out there host the
podcast and get a new job which is
interesting because I got a new job
before
um so Martin who I introduced before
from the study group just added a blue
messaged me and said hey you know I want
you to introduce you to the sky I think
you'd be a good fit so we hit it off and
I was like I really like this company
and I go to uh uh project summer Summit
for numb focus and I'm talking to
Katrina I was like hey I'm getting this
job at this company called Kung Fu AI
she was like Larry you need I got the
confirmation that I need it's like
that's the company you need to work for
like those are the guys right there so
it was like again Katrina coming around
I'm getting a job and she's like yes
that's the job for you right and so it
was great so these opportunities uh and
it all if you notice it all benefits
from the network and from the community
itself you able to deal with all the
resources and access the resources
within this community and then again
bring honesty humility and your
authentic self to every interaction and
this is the only way that this succeeds
that that's all I have to say
[Applause]
[Music]
any questions
yes
thank you so much
when you're talking about
the Diego program yes
can you go a little bit more into what
those are yeah so what I end up doing is
comprising a using a company called
click C on q-l-i-k
um they have free data alerts to
programs in which I was able to
construct from their materials and and
finagle them into a way that I could use
it at my work in the free so that was
the data literacy and I had a mandate
from my CEO that everyone in the
organization if we're going to be data
driven we need to everyone needs to take
this 40 minute like exercise all right
and not important I mean four hours it
was actually a big commitment it wasn't
it was four hours of learning for data
literacy uh the data science Playbook
was a way whenever I came in there was
no uniform way to do data science and
organization and so that was me spending
uh creating a 80 page document about how
we're going to do data science and kind
of making sure that how we interacted
with different departments we make sure
that everyone is actually taking
advantage of the data science uh on
product data science capabilities that
we had in our organization
so and just kind of laying it out how
that worked
so being very inclusive with everyone
that made marketing really wasn't
involved in data science before sales
was not involved in the data science
aspect and going out to them and saying
this is our Playbook that everyone we
should meet quarterly with the different
departments to understand their needs
and so it was a really big layout of
what was happening within the
organization how it should function
did that cover
okay
yes uh regarding your point about agile
faculty uh positions like for those of
us who may have been coming from other
fields and have been learning on the job
data science
um but are interested in uh these types
of teaching positions so that we can
uh reinforce our own skills
um how would you go about uh either one
demonstrating to a university or other
teaching program that you have the
requisite skills to teach or to prove to
yourself that you are ready for that
type of commitment so one other thing is
actual involvement within the community
that's a good way to demonstrate
especially with like open source
software showing that you can actually
like I work on a machine learning
package right that directly involved in
understanding how models work and I can
demonstrate that successfully and
um just whoever you're working with
figure there's different I'm trying to
think of the different ways that you can
demonstrate it but that interview is
really what the important thing is it
just during the interview asking simple
questions about the course of what's
being told you know like my courses
pandas is a really big deal like you
know what is your your current
understanding of pandas do you do it
proficiently you know how do you handle
a classroom these types of things or
what's important but I was isn't it took
me over my friend over a year to
convince me that I was ready in order to
do it I really felt like I was not
prepared to go teach someone it was like
you know you know this stuff a lot
better than you think you do so I would
encourage you to even try right and
don't worry about the fear of rejection
you know take it as an opportunity to
understand what people are requesting
and just put yourself out there right
you can always go back
so I know if you came to me and you were
not ready it's like you're just not
ready to teach this class that wouldn't
prevent you from coming to me in the
future and saying I want to participate
again I try again
that's
any more questions
I think that's
it so you can come up and speak to me if
you like
[Applause]